[Music]
some of you may have seen our
announcement with NetApp a few weeks ago
or you may have heard this in the
keynotes today or yesterday we've been
working with that up for a while to
build cloud volumes for GCP which we'll
talk about today and essentially the
vision is to build a high performance
file storage offering a fully managed
service that's integrated with DCP
something that supports multiple
protocols is very versatile you can
whether you're using NFS or you're using
SMB or if you looking for something that
integrates with kubernetes or any of the
GCP managed services the idea is to have
one file storage service that can can
provide that also if you're used to
advanced management features like like
snapshot snapshotting replication
cloning anyone the same thing in the
cloud this is the service that would
provide that also and what truly makes
this a partnership of firsts is if
you're if you're a Google cloud user GCP
user and you use used to our UI or you
used to our billing or working with
Google support none of that changes when
you use cloud volumes to GCP so
essentially the idea is to give you a
completely seamless experience if you're
using cloud volumes with Google cloud
platform and then you keep using the
tools that are used to when you use
Google Cloud now before I go further let
me quickly introduce the team that will
be joining me today in today's session
so my colleague from Google Devin
Lehmann he's been working with me under
this project and from NetApp we have a
limb Corrine I was a product manager for
cloud volumes and yangtze Steffensen who
is coming here all the way from Iceland
leaves cloud services and adapt so we're
going to keep this keep this light on
slides and focus more on demos just to
give you a quick overview of what you
can expect over the next few minutes so
we will have a limb talk about why
customers may want to use this service
some contexts around use cases we'll
talk about what this service really is
capabilities of the service what's
unique about this service and as well as
the architecture and then we're going
switch gears yeah Jhansi and Devon will
come on stage and do some cool demos and
talk about how do you create a cloud
volume or how do you create a snapshot
and how do you manage the the file
servers that you spin up in the cloud
and then a limb is gonna wrap up we're
talking about use cases and we'll do a
Q&A after that so with that I'll hand it
over to a limb to talk about cloud
volumes thanks everyone and thanks for
again attending an afternoon session so
let's get right to it again we want to
cover maybe two or three slides in the
beginning and really you know hand it
over to John see Devin and myself will
walk through the demo so before we get
too deep into the technical stuff what
we wanted to do was sort of step back
and look at this from more a strategic
point of view and really understand that
the customer context right so before we
develop cloud volumes we spent a lot of
time talking to customers and
understanding the nature of problems as
it related to unstructured data files
and public cloud and after analyzing
those all of those conversations what we
found was you could basically categorize
these problems into three main sets and
each of these three main sets had it had
a key persona so first you had a set of
application administrators application
owners that were trying to move
posix-compliant applications from
on-premise into GCP and they were doing
these for a variety of reasons right
perhaps they were shutting down a data
center perhaps they had a cloud for a
strategy perhaps they were trying to
modernize the application and the first
stage was to move it to GCP to do that
or perhaps they were supporting the
application was supporting a business
process that was variable in nature and
they wanted to take advantage of the
elasticity of the cloud to support that
business process so there was there's a
varying different you know things on on
why they were trying to do this but the
lack of enterprise-grade file services
in GCP essentially left them with two
options one you go through this massive
really textured process even though
there may not be anything wrong with the
architecture of your app it's risky it's
complex or you just say simply I'm not
going to move this application right so
we saw a problem there that that could
be solved the second set of people and
problems were a set of developers and
DevOps engineers that were either trying
to build
applications that required shared file
semantics in GCP or they were trying to
use workflows that require persistent
storage in GCP an example we've seen
over the last year come up a lot is
applications that are being refactored
to use containerized platforms and run
on gke
requiring persistent storage cloud
volumes is a good fit for that and then
finally we have a set of data analysts
and data engineers that have
unstructured data set on premise that
are trying to take those data sets to
the cloud to actually extract value out
of those data sets what we found common
across all these three problem sets is
the set of you know service expectations
so anything that solved these problems
had to have these three key things and
the one that bubbled up to the top this
notion of experience was pretty much
like the paramount thing and experience
here has multiple facets it's not just
about how well integrated the product is
from a look and feel perspective into
GCP but users really wanted a consistent
experience with Google so that means
support that means billing that means
operations in a multitude of other
product related aspects deeply
integrated into GCP and that's what we
focused on to bring with cloud volumes
the other two pieces are on consumption
and economics actually go hand-in-hand
right so with the ability for or this
thing being a true cloud service they
expect consumption to be able to go up
and down and the economics should match
that pattern so now let's talk about
cloud volumes for GCP and the various
elements involved and again this is more
of a a service overview slide and we'll
talk about the technical details here in
a second but the simplest way to think
about cloud volumes for gcp is that they
are a simple to consume performant NFS
or SMB endpoint it's a no op service so
you as an application owner or as a
developer simply just consume that NFS
or SMB endpoint you don't have to worry
about any of the infrastructure related
tasks around setting things up patching
things maintaining things scaling things
that's handled seamlessly between an app
and Google you just get the NFS or SMB
endpoint that you're interested in
the second thing around native user
experience and and that demo will really
show you what we mean by that but the
engineering teams have spent a ton of
time integrating this so that it looks
and feels exactly like any other Google
service right to the point where there
is no separate punch out there's no
separate you is how you authenticate
into the Google Cloud console stays
consistent as you move into the service
so there's a security element to this
integration as well and I can describe
it all I want but you'll get to see it
firsthand so net app has had a rich
history in data management over the last
20 years and we're bringing all of that
goodness to cloud volumes the ability to
take snapshots the ability to then
create rapid copies out of these
snapshots and the ability to synchronize
data that's all coming to cloud volumes
support is another thing we hear from
customers about a lot right oftentimes
when we talk about new products we focus
on the beginning right it's like what
does the user interface look like and
how well is that integrated but it we
have to think about the life cycle of
the product right and things will go
wrong and customers want to know that
there is an integrated support system to
help them when things do go wrong so
with cloud volumes to GCP support is
actually integrated with Google in that
l1 support is offered by Google Google
always answers the support call and
Google always maintains the customer
relationship with the customer they may
escalate the net up in the back but
Google always owns the customer
relationship moving on to some of the
elements on the right-hand side so this
is a cloud service right it offers a
true Pago consumption model it's based
on allocated capacity and you can vary
the amount of allocated capacity over
the course of a month billing is
integrated into GCP as well so all of
that allocated capacity that you consume
over a month is billed directly through
through Google you don't get any other
separate invoices or things from that up
everything happens through GCP again
keeping within that same ecosystem and
then finally you know we're going to
enable hybrid enablement for the service
in that we're going to allow customers
to move data both from on-premise and
other SMB or NFS services into cloud
volumes and then the region piece we're
going to start this service in u.s. East
4 we're going to roll out two
the regions in the US by the end of the
year as well as some regions in Europe
and we'll cover that towards the end of
the presentation so one thing that is
very unique about cloud volumes for GCP
is this notion of service levels and so
it you know bears a few minutes it's
worth talking about
so think about cloud volumes coming in
three flavors and these three flavors
are identical in terms of the protocols
they offer as well as the rich data
management features that they offer so
across these three flavors you get SMB
or NFS you get snapshots you get copies
you get data synchronization how these
three service levels differ is in the
amount of performance that you get per
allocated terabyte of capacity right so
the three service levels are listed here
standard premium and extreme in the case
of standard you get 16 megabytes per
terabyte allocated in the case of
premium 64 megabytes per terabyte
allocated and in the case of extreme 128
megabytes per terabyte allocated why did
we do this we did this because customers
are gonna use cloud volumes for
different use cases right so if you're
doing virtualized applications if you're
doing general-purpose databases premium
is probably where you want to start if
you're doing high-performance computing
if you're doing genomic analysis extreme
is where you want to go right but we
also give you the flexibility to change
these tiers because oftentimes we hear
from customers we kind of know but we're
not sure so start off with one and
you're free to change it to another one
so before we go into the demo just one
quick technical slide on what the
building blocks are and what this
architecture looks like right so in this
case on on the far side we have the
cloud volume service this is where
you're provision and get your volumes
from on the on this side on the left
hand side we actually have a GCP project
you have a region in that project you
have a set of instances within a given
VPC and all of those instances have
access to cloud volumes and you can
control this access using export
policies and you'll see this in the demo
and on in terms of how we secure these
cloud volumes the key thing I want to
point out here is that cloud volumes are
a regionally accessible resource so even
if if you have compute incidences in
zone 1 zone 2 zone 3 in a given region
all of those compute instances can
access cloud volumes in that given
region so with that the engineering guys
told me don't go more than three or four
slides so I kept to that limit and now
I'm gonna bring them on to actually talk
about the product itself and give us a
demo so you don't see Devin please hey
guys hey everybody we actually want this
to be as interactive as possible so if
you have a question we be here with a
feeling that we hate slides and we would
always and everybody said hey you guys
are not doing a live demo of course
we're doing a live demo even though it's
from a stating environment right all the
bells and whistles so we actually want
it to be really interactive so if you
have questions just raise your hand and
we'll stop and answer all those
questions so how many you're familiar
with the on tap UI itself awesome okay
so one of the big things we'll Lim
highlighted early on is that this is the
first standalone service within CCP
that's going to look like a third-party
service so everything within cloud
console the provisioning of volume is
gonna be the same thing you used to in
the dev environment so we thought just
to kick things off you kind of show you
the discovery phase within marketplace
let me go into the solution and kind of
click around and see what's happening so
with that you searched knit up launched
a solution you're gonna have the
overview it's gonna talk it's an adopt
solution running within cloud console
the types of services and its own
updated things like that but it brings
you right into the volumes page so again
if you used to see in cloud volumes are
going to notice things like the name the
region is deployed in the lifecycle the
service level the usage and what's
reserved for snapshots yeah and you can
actually customize like you can in
everything in in TCP you can actually
customize the way your transport
actually looks like if you want to pop
up for example who the project owner is
what region it is in and the
availability or they isolate tiers that
you have actually selected a few other
things to note here is that that
transition between the marketplace and
this particular view as I mentioned
earlier and you see it that there's no
other authentication or punch out that
you have to do it's just seamless it
just goes from the launcher in to this
particular you
why the other thing to also note here is
that the service levels in all of the
columns but the volumes always exist in
the context of a Google project just
like any other Google resource within a
project if you have two separate
projects it's two separate sets of
volumes volumes in a project always
exist within the context of a project
yeah so going through the creation
process again should be similar to what
you're used to in the past but click
create a volume choose with our sin FS
or SMB and to your name you'll see we've
done this a few times choose the volume
path and then choose the service level
so something that's super important with
this particular solution itself is
subjective to what's going on in time of
year subject to the industry reusing you
can toggle back and forth between
service level subject with the
performance you're asking for yeah the
the service level is I mean you can
actually view the the UI as being
stateless every single action within the
UI is an API call so you can actually
automate that beyond API and for example
if you are having like seasonal spikes
or or you know that the traffic that is
coming in at 4 o'clock you can actually
switch on the fly between standard
premium and extreme by doing that we
actually have like a scheduler that
actually looks at if the controller is
congested then it actually moves and
migrates the volume so this is something
that we felt like was really really
important to be able to meet these
unexpected loads and you should be able
to do it on the fly yeah I go on along
the same path you select the region
which you want to pull in if you want to
create a snapshot for this particular
view and then your allocated capacity 5
terabytes from here it's if you're a DCP
user it's gonna be a similar experience
as well you choose a percentage of
snapshots you like there's a little
great slider and then we can choose
export policies which is something a
limb talked about earlier so that and
this is this is really where you get to
secure that volume right and security
obviously in the cloud is important but
there's multiple different aspects this
really controls who has access to this
particular volume and how they have
access so you can actually limit it to a
specific client by specifying one
P address and you can say that client
has read-only access or you can do side
arranges right saying these clients
within a subnet 10 clients 50 clients
whatever it is all have either read only
or read/write access this is how
security for the volume is managed and
within the security protocols as well we
can then choose the snapshot policy so
if you want to go hourly daily weekly
monthly easy use usually consumable
within GP so we're gonna save that
volume it's gonna load it's gonna go
back under the overview what you're just
looking at before and so typically at
this point right it's like you've gone
through you've created a volume in this
case we showed creating an NFS volume
you create an export policy now it's
ready to be consumed right so the next
thing you want to do is actually look at
how you would mount this volume inside
of your clients to access it so than
that we've built it in the straighten of
the UI you just choose the toggle or the
hamburger menu on the right mount
instructions and you're gonna see the
standard calls that you make from your
CLI over a particular API we actually
have it here where you can just copy
directly and then fire up your terminal
and by your volunteer for the computer
you're using I think it's really great
for any particular user because you
don't have to cover two different
interfaces and again just drag and drop
and maybe show the difference to like
most instructions for SMB as well so one
of the things that we are actually going
to be introducing is you can actually
have multiple protocols on the same
volume so you can actually service both
Windows and Linux clients within from
the same data set and and this is
something that we've heard again from
customers about is that they have
basically treating these volumes as a
high performance bus between
applications like in in health care they
have applications that are unix-based
applications that are windows-based and
they need a way to share this data so
these volumes act like a common
repository across two very different
architectures to enable that sharing of
data to happen and I'm surprised we
haven't gotten even one one question yet
someone must be curious about something
yeah
permissions yes yeah so you can actually
show if you go into the Active Directory
connection so you actually have to have
your own Active Directory server running
within that project so it has not
attacked a network yeah yep
so so that's how you are actually taking
care of and for example for nfsv4 you
need Kerberos and alt up and all of that
so so that's all taken care of a big in
the beginning we're only doing NFS v3
and SMB when we're introducing nfsv4
then we there will be an additional tab
that is doing the LDAP configuration and
to answer your specific question around
security rights as Jonesy said as we
introduced the both mode what we will go
into is that what kind of security style
do you want on the volume right because
you as the you know as the owner of the
volume have to pick is it NTFS or is it
unix-style securities how are the
underlying ECL is actually managed right
and that differs between how you do file
sharing between units and Windows so
we're gonna give users to control to be
able to specify that as well as to Jung
this point linked up to an ad server
that says ok this is how my names names
are being managed and stuff
an API yep we thought that would be the
first question yeah absolutely so I mean
like I said everything in the UI is
stateless so it's actually an API call
so this is something that Google and not
that we actually build together and and
we are we're gonna expose that next
month chorus on it it's pressure
but but yeah so I mean we've also been
for example doing our terraform for
example scripting so it actually
supports terraform so if you wanna
automatically provision everything with
with or any configuration management
tool yeah absolutely
yeah the end goal here is there's been
so much work to get these UI is
integrated together from the control
frame perspective but as a developer
many don't go to you eyes right so you'd
like to use the CEO and the API and it's
the directions were eventually having
and many of the you know even the the
modifications that we talked about on
how how you can go and edit these
volumes right so it's changing service
levels for example it's hard to say okay
you know on Friday night I'm gonna go
login to the UI and then change it from
extreme to premium or vice versa
all right these are these are things
that exactly you would script and put as
part of a as a business process for a
batch run or seasonal update or whatever
it is oh go to the microphone is you
guys are fine it's too late now
or just speak up and we can reiterate
yeah yes so we've basically completely
mapping the use of topology of TCP so so
projects how you share what policies you
put in place actually gets adopted in
here so again if you're used to log in
and use quad SIBO right in ten tears to
have no different experience so you log
into console username and password to
service and you should be and we've
we've differentiated it a little bit in
terms of the discovery piece right so
you need to be a project owner to enable
the service right because now you're
talking about something that say a
billable thing right so you need to be
an owner to enable it but once you once
you once you're done that then it's like
editors in the project have access to be
able to go create it we do we do have
some thoughts around how we introduce
more granular I am right like down to
create update delete type permissions
but that's something that we introduce
later on
yeah
so right now it's a physical failure is
a physical fire or is it sitting
somewhere in a desert yeah yeah so so I
mean the the the software aspect is we
have multiple service levels and service
level might for example be the lowest
service level might be pure software and
then premium if you want to reach like
for example with genome sequencing we
had an amazing company as one of our
private preview customers that me really
needed high-performance storage to do to
genome sequencing so we would never be
never have been able to meet that on
pure software so so so the the I think
the top tiers are always gonna be harder
and I think I think the the way we
wanted to abstract us away from
customers right is give them an SLO
based endpoint all right and then it's
up to us with Google to engineer the
data plane to meet that SLO
that's that's up that's off to us to
manage right now hence hence it being a
cloud service and we here we want
customers to focus on the endpoint and
the SLO off that endpoint hmm and and
and leave it to us to worry about or
have sleepless nights we will have to
put something in the UI that says you
know too many zeros tell this number
three
yeah yeah so so for example if you
provision 1/10 terabyte volume you're
actually getting 10 times 128 and what
what so 1.2 gigabytes a second so we've
actually been able to live up to that
which is awesome and we actually have a
customer that actually reaches its it
reached higher than that but the the
very sort of flatten out around 12 to 14
terabytes that's when the it doesn't
scale endlessly of course but that's
where we're sort of cutting out it's
linear until that point there and then
fastened
devyn you want to take that so yeah we
can all kind of take us out of this one
but the the usage coming from those
particular users right so people are
using NetApp aren't all of a sudden
gonna jump ship and use a completely
different file technology well she's a
good example of that they've been very
very awesome and being a co announcer's
of our particular partnership in general
right they're using on tap solution and
they're very excited to use the GCP
solution as well for particular new
users maybe SMB markets or those who are
going through a start-up phase that
aren't gonna drop a bunch of gear and a
particular data center might use file
store but there's a yin and yang for
which solutions you're proud of my
introducing and that's that you know
from a customer perspective you know
we've had that question come up in
customers they've kind of given us an
answer right which is you know for basic
needs
yeah NFS v3 whatever file store is okay
right but as soon as you talk and you
start talking about a service that is
more feature oriented like this one
where you can change service levels you
can have advanced data management
features you can have multi protocol
true multi-protocol from a single volume
these are kind of things where what when
earlier when I talked about the customer
context and customers wanting to move
applications that were filed based POSIX
space to the cloud these are the kind of
services that they need
right it's C if it was just about
providing a simple NFS here you stand up
a single node file server and you have
that right you don't even need a service
you need a service when it gets into the
enterprise with these kind of features
but you kind of stole my thunder but
from the from our point of view at
Google I think this is it's all about
customer choice so having multiple
services with some features being
available in a particular service it
helps customers and that's we're working
towards today if you're looking for it
for example SMB you can't do that with
file store you can do that with cloud
volumes to give you an example and if
you're looking for a no sequel database
there are multiple no sequel database
options that are available to our
customers and so in the similar vein
we're working on both both the offerings
for our customers
yeah yeah yes yes yes
so something the product manager should
have covered earlier here yeah so the
the pricing is actually separate for
each of the service tiers and how we do
this is based on allocated capacity but
lease the call it these queue is
changeable right so if you allocate five
terabytes today of premium and in one
week you change that to be extreme right
we track the SKU with Google in the back
end so the billing engine will build you
one week's worth of usage on premium and
then one week's worth of usage on
extreme or whatever your whatever your
capacity ends up being so the
flexibility is mirrored by the
underlying economics yeah yeah so it's
it's right so it's it's true pay go in
the sense that if you start with five
terabytes of premium you can change that
to five terabytes of extreme in the
middle of the month right so if if
Premium is thirty cents a gig and
extreme is forty cents a gig it'll be
the average of those two is what you're
gonna pay at the end of the month which
storage media something that gives you
either 16 64 or 128 megabytes four
terabytes stored again focus on the
performance SLO
no not at the moment and we wanted to
keep this consistent with how GCP does
resource management right and that's
that's been - yawns his earlier point
the core design principle right keep it
like a resource within a project that's
isolated within a project and we haven't
really come up with with any kind of use
cases or customer information that said
across project sharing is needed I don't
know what's gonna add to that yeah
actually I mean this is something that
do you really want to look into because
let's say you have your development team
that is actually developing and then
they want to push it and they want to
take some of some take advantage of
being able to clone a volume that's
going from development to staging and
then to production and that might be
totally different projects so I really
understand as a developer I really
understand the the flow should really be
there and that's what we are really
looking into I'm really glad you asked
that question because I also been
fighting to actually get it implemented
but so I I really get the use case for
that yeah right good good question good
question so the question was that is
this a an XP n shared projects when
Google you have the the ability to
create a parent project and then child
projects underneath which shared
resources firewall rules and such so
right now we're talking about a flat
topology right so it's the service is
available within the project that you
provision in that it's cross like the
ability to do cross project networking
and actually have a hierarchy of
projects that's something we're gonna
introduce later there's really there's
some technical things but mostly it's
just you know testing and queuing that's
set up and making sure it works so at
the moment think about it as a flat in
in project tree in the same project
resource
yeah yeah more of a testing thing
yeah they need the performance but they
don't need the capacity so then my
answering and I'm sure you'll see has
has his but my answer is that when
you're when you're procuring a cloud
volume you're actually paying for a
resource that has two dimensions right
you have a capacity dimension and a
performance dimension and you're gonna
pay for you're gonna pay for what you
need the most right so if you need
capacity you're gonna pay for capacity
if you need performance you're gonna
over allocate capacity in order to get
the performance you need that's why we
also have service tiers to be able to be
you know a little bit more flexible with
that and not so rigid but in some cases
you're gonna have to over provision yeah
I mean we were really really lucky when
when it came to private preview
customers I mean we basically got every
single flavor of workloads so we could
actually work really closely with all
those customers one of them was running
Oracle databases on file and they've
always been running that unblocked for
example but they were actually
clustering it so it was multi hosted
hats so they're actually getting way
better performance or throughput on on
fires they we saw that they were over
provisioning even though the database
might have been like a terabyte they
almost all of them they were
provisioning 10 12 14 terabytes to
actually get the perform so to your
point what was very value what what was
the biggest value for them was actually
finally they actually could run those
Oracle workloads in a public cloud and
they they and they hadn't been able to
do that until with the cloud volumes so
we so it was actually yeah you can see
you can see that that you're paying for
way more capacity than you're actually
using but sometimes you have to pay for
what you need that yes you need
performance so I'd like just a highlight
that really quickly tea so working with
net app in this particular partnership
it's been instrumental in getting
projects like this off the ground so
their customers are fantastic with
feedback their customers are fantastic
and saying what doesn't work and what
does
and the I did this is that's what you're
seeing on the screen today sorry does
there's another question yeah yes no so
we we already have like in our staging
environment with Google we already have
cloud sync or not a cloud sync that is
actually can synchronize from nine point
to end point and is agnostic when it
comes to filers if you're asking about
something like snot mirror or something
that's actually retaining deduplication
and compression during transfer this no
it's not but I mean that's something
that we are really looking into but the
thing is it's actually a single tenant
environment a cluster right variable
that is being pushed to a multi tenant
and Google would you say guys crazy
you're not a breach of all security
protocols basically because you're
taking something from a single tenant
and the way it's actually required but
NASA and Google we are actually working
on reducing the granularity of that so
you can actually set it on a volume
level and if that's the case then we can
introduce not mirror probably revealing
something that I'm not allowed to like
always
[Laughter]
so yeah that's actually a great question
so we we have a scheduler that is
running that is actually monitoring if
the controller is congested if it can
actually handle changing the service
level if it's congested or can't handle
those 128 megabytes a second it's it's
moved and we take care of that with the
scheduler so that everything is
automatic yeah yeah it happens
automatically yes our billing
granularity right now is per hour as we
monitor capacity within a given hour we
have multiple data points within the
hour that we average out but the idea is
to make it even more granular but we
figured at least to start with with the
pay-go option we'll do hourly monitoring
every hour or is pushing metric billing
metrics every hour
right yeah it's a good question so Pago
basically is is where we wanted to start
like a cloud service but what we want to
introduce also is this notion of being
able to do subscriptions write
subscriptions and you can use a
different term but essentially customers
that want to commit for a volume of
capacity for a given duration you get a
certain discount right what those things
are we're still working through and
trying to figure out what you know what
the sweet spots are in terms of is it a
is it a hundred terabytes for twelve
months or is it a petabyte for twelve
months and we're gonna introduce those
there's always gonna be sort of you know
edge cases right but we do want to have
some standard subscription off options
directly in the cloud that said that you
have to use this much capacity and
you're committing to use it for this
amount of time you will get billed
monthly but in exchange for that term
and volume you're gonna get a discount
of X percent just view it as like
bundles a bundle that's actually been
like one of the feature requests from
our private preview customers is
actually to introduce that as well yes
that's a different question yes it is is
it integrate with staff driver for
monitoring so you can like you reporting
everything yes
not directly
alright so the way the support workflow
works is that the customer contacts
Google Google does basically l1 to l2
support and if there are issues with
whatever the infrastructure is or
whatever the software is running in the
background
those issues are escalated between
NetApp and Google NetApp may get pulled
in to solve certain customer problems
but it's always Google owning the
support relationship there may be
another person there to help solve but
Google Google and the customer are where
the support endpoints are yeah that's
one of the things that we really wanted
to emphasize I mean although you'll have
a single billing you have a single
support contact you have a single
contact for everything and that's Google
so it should be at we wanted to have it
as integrated in all areas as possible
so so it's been really good I mean and
it's been a it's been a fantastic
journey I mean we've been doing like
these code sessions code jam sessions
with Google and NAT up so I mean it's
been a true partnership and it's it's
actually really proud of what it is oft
it in oh yeah I just read that from the
Google side it really is a joint effort
to get something like this up and
running especially if this holistically
integrated and alone was saying from a
user perspective you should be able to
come as the GCP user never standing up
on top and totally understand the
experience and vice versa like going
into on tap never go into GCP firing it
up and having a great experience it's a
great question
not as long as you would think yeah good
answer does that mean you're not
answering or no the product manager said
it right there no yeah
yeah yep that allocated capacity is a
flexible number and you can change in
any time you want it is actually like a
soft quota so it's not like a hard limit
you can actually go above it and will
actually pick it up in the building so
you can actually if in some weird cases
you don't want the performance and and
you allocated a terabyte and you can you
can you can shoot over that it's a soft
code so it's not like if you're running
a database you don't want it to stop or
corrupt the database you want it to be
able to scale up so so it's a soft quota
and it's more for you to manage and get
the expected performance out of the and
and again as I mentioned this is
monitored every hour from a billing
perspective so if you change the
capacity halfway through the month it's
only halfway through the month that
you're billed for the higher capacity
yes sir ah wondering when that would
come up so regions we're starting in
u.s. East four and our plan is that by
the end of the year we'll be live in
u.s. central one as well as Europe West
3 which is Frankfurt and then we will be
adding other regions in the US in 2019
on the west coast as well and when if
you go to like create volume I don't
know if you guys saw that you can
actually have like a region switcher
so you can actually if you had
subscribed to cloud volumes in multiple
regions we would basically just select
here where you want to provision
also right now these are available
availabilities within a region
accessible to all zones within a region
available within a region but we're not
we're not doing cross region yet it's
something that we have on the roadmap
the ability to be able to have a cloud
volume in one region replicated to a
cloud volume in another region mm-hmm
that's something that we're gonna bring
later on but it's not there right now
yeah okay and you can go into the SLA so
that the up times and everything that
you're you already started go ahead no
dude okay I think it's six nice
durability yeah yeah so but it's it's
tied to within a region
so yeah Calum said I mean on top already
has all these features I mean we're
basically just slowly integrating it
into TCP or into the cloud volumes so
you have like cross side the application
built in and two on top that's just how
you're actually doing that on a mostly
Tennessee level mostly tenant level so
we're looking into all of that zone and
and basically you know there there's
going to be additional things we add but
really when we talk to customers as I
said in the beginning right it was just
this this core notion of having an NFS
or SMB endpoint with these features was
really where they were stuck in terms of
being able to either deploy or move new
applications that's why this is kind of
in our super focus for the initial
payload and then the add-ons will come
over time and I actually think it says a
lot about the rate of development
because when we stuffed it on the first
private preview customers came and they
only got a month point then we
introduced on to month snapshots not
your policy export policy then cloud
sync is coming even cloud backup is
coming where you can actually backup
data from cloud volumes to the Google
object storage so it's all in the rate
of development has been really really
fast
and the features that we have been
introducing and it was kind of funny
because many of the our private preview
customers they were like okay not a real
cloud company now because they always
and so features just popping up
within the Google console like so it's
yeah I mean it's been and we are nowhere
stopping I mean we're going to continue
with the innovation and the partnership
and and yeah it's good
so we kept it to four slides or five
yeah you want to go another title but
and I think actually this is having this
interactive session and and having you
guys ask the questions these really were
what the rest of the slides are about
what regions how do I get billed how do
I do this how do I do that so I think
we're almost out of time but at least
from my perspective the the to yonce
this point the partnership goes beyond
we're standing here doing this because
of a broad team at NetApp and Google
that supports us our business
development team Lena and vendor
engineering team hats off to these guys
for pulling this off operations teams
that integrate with support so I mean
it's all around it's been a it's been a
fantastic partnership to get us to where
we are and we're really excited done on
what this can do for customers it's all
we had thank you
[Applause]
[Music]